Al Gore you may remember Al Gore also
failed presidential candidate who has
run around and made millions and
millions of dollars making people think
that the sky is falling Al Gore also
gave a talk now you're going to see this
video of Al Gore if you haven't seen Al
Gore lately you're going to think this
is a man wearing an Al Gore suit but we
confirm this is actually video of Al
Gore uh take a look
I don't want to get
tracked on to what needs to happen but
we need to scale up climate Finance but
we need desperately to scale down
anti-climate Finance
and we are still subsidizing the burning
of fossil fuels globally at a rate 42
times larger than the subsidies for the
shift toward Renewables and EVS
Etc we need new leadership at the World
Bank we need them to scale up the
leverage and vastly increase the amounts
that are are committed and we need to
rein in the anti-climate activities of
the fossil industry oh they need to rein
in those activities of those of us who
want gas stove so do you see how these
things are all connected and yes that
actually is Al Gore
apparently not wearing a fat suit that's
just what's happened to him it looks
like he's filled with jelly okay you'd
think you'd be cutting down on the eaten
if you really cared about the
environment right you'd think you'd be
doing that Al Gore Al Gore by the way if
you want to talk about grifters and
charlatans please Google this Al Gore
when he left the White House as Bill
Clinton's VP he started a cable channel
called current TV that some of you may
remember it was a complete failure of a
cable channel it was it was going to be
like a a lefty socialist sort of Bernie
Sanders New Media uh Cable News Channel
like to compete with CNN and MSNBC and
fox Etc using all of his connections as
vice president he was able to get on all
the cable channels so you could get on
Comcast you could get on DirecTV et
cetera et cetera that's the hard part of
building a cable channel right because
you have to have all of the connections
so he leveraged his connections as vice
president to get on all the cable
channels he creates a failure of a
network the network never made money the
programming was awful nobody was
watching then and you know what he did
Al Gore Google this please Google this
he sold current TV which was worth
nothing except that it had access to the
cable channels it had nothing that
anyone was buying nobody was buying the
programming nobody was buying any of the
stuff that they had created
he sold it for 500 million dollars
to Qatar yeah he sold it to Al Jazeera
which is obviously state-sponsored media
from Qatar Qatar if I'm not mistaken is
the number two exporter of
um fossil fuels
how bizarre that Al Gore did that
[Music]
foreign
[Music]